this week on quadriga al Qaeda spent
force or global threat the United States
and its allies closed more than 20
diplomatic posts across the Middle East
and North Africa this week amid fear of
an imminent al Qaeda attack the threat
focused on Yemen there the u.s.
evacuated its diplomats and urged its
citizens to leave the country media
reports say the scare was triggered by
intercepted messages that revealed al
Qaeda was planning to carry out major
terrorist attacks following the death of
Osama bin Laden the terror network was
thought to be on the run is it now
beginning to bounce back your host this
week Elias lon hello and welcome to
quadriga while al-qaeda is a global
phenomenon and has since evolved into a
global brand and thread but before nine
eleven only the most prolific
counterterrorism experts had even heard
all this terrorist organization so the
question is is al Qaeda still a global
threat or a spent force that's what I
want to talk about on today show
together with these three experts
welcome to yah Teemu char baj he's an
investigative reporter for the German
national weekly newspaper deepside an
expert on terrorism he's the author of
several books such as the new al Qaeda
and his recent novel a decal and Ruby
Dennison is an American political
scientist and the director of the
foreign policy think-tank transatlantic
networks he also serves frequently as a
commentator on German radio and
television and ft sam ali hussein is an
Egyptian political scientist based here
in Berlin she's also an expert on Muslim
societies and writes articles for
various Arabic media outlets
welcome to the show and Ruby Dennison
about 20 u.s. consulates and embassies
have been closed due to this perceived
threat by al-qaeda due to these
intercepted intercepted conversations
between very high-ranking al-qaeda
officials now a lot of people are saying
these closings are somewhat of an
overreaction on the part of the US
government would you agree well I think
a lot of your viewers have been to
American embassies or two American
consulates to get a visa to study or to
vacation in America or for some other
reason and I think for those people who
stand outside in line sometimes you go
to a embassy in the morning there'll be
a hundred people standing there for
those people it does make sense I think
American embassies are such well
fortified positions that unless you have
a huge mob that has a long time you're
not going to actually get in and get
American diplomats but still the tragedy
if a crowd of people outside the embassy
waiting to go to America we're justifies
i would say these precautionary measures
so you'd rather be safe than sorry yeah
c mu shabaash aside from possibly
overreacting a lot of people are also
questioning the timing of these
perceived threats by al-qaeda in fact
the question and rather the idea that is
being put forth is that it comes at a
very convenient time namely in the midst
of the so-called NSA controversy and
there are some voices out there who see
the closing of the embassies and the
illusion if you will to this thread as a
welcome distraction of this color
discussion would you agree no no I don't
agree I mean I think first of all I
don't think it's welcome it's not a
distraction that is welcomed by anyone
in the US for sure and secondly I think
the basis of this theory is a
misconception the NSA is in the middle
of a lot of criticism in parts of
western europe but not so much in the
u.s. so they don't have to justify
themselves for what they are doing and
doing but the US Congress has taken up
this issue yes but not to an extent that
I would think that the NSA or the
security services a colon in the US
would think it's necessary to start this
sort of distortion on purpose and
there's also another reason why I don't
think this is the case what we are
seeing now is that the US are publicly
sending a signal to al Qaeda that they
are afraid this is a this is a victory
for al Qaeda in and of itself and nobody
would do that voluntarily and after
Somalia saying a similar brush touches
upon an important point indeed the
critics out there of the latest closing
of the US Embassy are saying the US has
showed its hand by by making public this
threat and therefore has emboldened al
Qaeda even further is that also your
line of thinking well at Georgetown
professor just made it clear that that
al Qaeda is doing pretty good just by
waving and saying we're going to do
something even if they are not serious
about it because the Americans are like
freaking out I do not agree I mean I
think it's right and it's correct what
they're doing right now that they are
shuttering the embassies and everything
but I mean this is how he sees it that
really al Qaeda is doing a good job
because they just imply that they are
going to do something and then everyone
is like scared and trying to do
something about it do you think it's
realistic that this perhaps could have
been even for lack of a better term a
prank by Al Qaeda sort of testing the
waters this is actually another reason
to believe that they're doing a pretty
good job because if they are talking on
mobile phones that are easily traced by
American intelligence CIA then they are
probably like bluffing they wouldn't
mean to like really attack embassies
while saying that on mobile phones that
could be easily traced so you have the
whole conspiracy theory of whether they
really mean it they don't mean it but
that the US is making up the threat in
order to justify though for the prism
scandal it's really convoluted yes I
Michelle but you don't seem to agree
with the theory of this being a bluff
yeah I beg I beg to differ a little bit
because i think it is entirely possible
that
some communication between al-qaeda
leaders will be picked up it doesn't
happen all the time and yes you are
right they are very careful but they are
not super careful all the time and as of
this time we do not exactly know what
kind of information was picked up
there's all sorts of rumors half of them
I don't buy a phone conference with
people from 20 countries I don't think
that happened at all but online
communication that was picked up because
it wasn't hidden well enough or not
encrypted well enough that's entirely
possible now what did they exactly say
and did they say start a huge operation
against the Americans as soon as you can
we don't know I don't know I'm a
journalist I'm not an intelligence
officer so you know I think my job our
job should rather be to ask is it
plausible not is it true we can't know
if it's true if we don't have the actual
original information and and Ruby
Dennison of course we don't know what
the message was that was intercepted by
US intelligence officers but we have to
take their word for it that this is the
most serious threat that the US has seen
in several years a lot of people are
also saying in the community in the
expert community if you will that the
timing is very peculiar namely that it
coincides with the naming of na CL why
she as the new number two of al-qaeda he
of course is the leader of the al-qaeda
in the Arabian Peninsula the al-qaeda
branch and affiliate in Yemen that make
it make it a good point that this
significant step with Warren Americans
against flying too close so many
embassies other countries Germany as
close embassies as well this significant
step would not be made just on the basis
of a few intercepts of communications
alone there's a word that's often used
in the intelligence community chatter
chatter you everyone talking at once
whatever that means but people do
indicate there have been numerous
signals that something might be coming
and as we've heard the cost of taking
these precautionary measures is high
financially and of course all of the
jihadis in the world will say look how
strong we are we got them to close
I don't think there is any political
connection to the NSA scandal but there
is another political connection and that
is Benghazi September 11th yes Benghazi
was attacked Christopher Hitchens three
others killed that has been an ongoing
scandal in American politics since then
whether Obama and yo and Hillary Clinton
were cautious enough and did the right
things to protect American personnel so
we do probably see here extra caution
because of the Benghazi effect if you
will the Benghazi effect and the
ramifications still being discussed in
u.s. politics I mean I can my
understanding is that nowhere in the
intercept does it say that the targets
are going to be diplomatic institutions
and still I do understand why the US are
trying to protect those in particular
not only because of Benghazi but also
because one of the the earliest in
biggest al-qaeda attacks we've seen
where the bombings in nairobi and dar
Salam in 98 and with hundreds of dead
people so I understand that and the
problem I see is now for how long are
you going to close these embassies
because if I put myself in the shoes of
Ayman al-zawahiri or Nasser al-wahishi I
probably say okay well I'm not going to
do it now now that everybody's looking
i'm probably going to wait a month or
two because at some point you know
everything is going to be going back to
normal so this is the problem that I see
with making this very public and very
and giving the impression that this is
very imminent and you don't think there
was a wise move on the part of the u.s.
to perhaps make it public in order to
interrupt well I'll kind of planning see
this is this is the thing did they make
it public so that al-qaeda would not do
it did they make it public because they
took it so seriously and thought it
might be very imminent we do not know at
least I don't and it does make sense to
take extra precautions the question is
um is d is the publicity that came with
the whole thing and too much it probably
is i'm not sure about will be all the
wiser in a while because you know right
now it's it's futile to speculate about
an attack that didn't happen we don't
know what the case was but we do know
that not just the president and the
administration but also members of
Congress Democrats and Republicans have
had a look at some of the indications
and have come to the conclusion that
this was correct and I think also aware
of that additional problem when do you
turn the warning down and I hope they
thought about that we shouldn't forget
though that everyone will try to take
advantage of the situation al Qaeda of
course but also American and and Allied
intelligence agencies will look at how
all the different threatening groups
jihad is Al Qaeda's whatever you want to
call how they respond because the game
doesn't ever stop certainly the closings
in the closings of the embassy has
certainly been widely publicized in the
Western media certainly in the United
States how is this story being reported
in the Arabic news and the Arabic media
world I was in Egypt a few days ago and
we kind of heard about it it was in the
news and people kind of believed in the
series of the seriousness of the threats
because Amon is law Harry one leading
member of the al-qaeda had already made
very negative comments on the last move
of the military against the Muslim
Brotherhood president where he was
ousted so things seem to go in
consistency and they go together in the
same line yeah al-qaeda is outraged
because of what happened in Egypt and
now there's the thread that there might
be attacks yeah the US embassies can be
targets of such attacks so generally
speaking the people in Egypt they
believe in the seriousness of the threat
what went wrong here i mean let's look
at what president obama said only a few
months ago at the National Defense
University he said the war on terror has
been won its over and al Qaeda is
defeated that's the statement by the US
president only a few months ago now he's
rushing to close you know 20-something
embassies and consulates worldwide in
answer if you will as a real
chin to an al-qaeda threat what do you
make of this I think you have to
distinguish between tactical threats and
strategic threats and the president
meant that an al-qaeda capable of doing
in 911 again enjoying a sanctuary where
it can hide in safety to organize a
massive plan like that that al-qaeda is
really significantly less threatening
than it has been in the past also two
American soldiers who are no longer
deployed in such large numbers in Iraq
or in Afghanistan on top of that we have
found a new way instead of deploying
hundred thousand soldiers we have a
squadron of unmanned aircraft that
follow bad guys for weeks until they
think they've got a good shot like we've
seen in the Amon in the last couple of
weeks again and on top of this America
does like information security excuse me
superiority we would like to listen to
everything that any suspected bad guy in
the world communicates over the internet
so a different way of fighting a weaker
al-qaeda nevertheless one that has
tactically benefited from the chaos and
the arms in the Middle East following
the Arab Spring and therefore is a
threat but at a different level it's a
threat but at a different level says and
will be denison but one thing is for
sure al Qaeda is still here after 911 it
is still here even off the after the
death of Osama bin Laden al Qaeda is
still here and perhaps here to stay
let's have a quick look
it's been called the decade of terror in
the ten years that followed the 911
attacks extreme Islamist groups took aim
at the US and Europe killing thousands
of people
Western nations reacted on a massive
scale two wars were launched in the
so-called war on terror in May 2011
American special forces finally tracked
down and killed the al-qaeda leader
Osama bin Laden who was hiding in
Pakistan Ayman al-zawahiri an Egyptian
took over from bin Laden but he isn't as
influential as his predecessor al Qaeda
is now thought to be made up of mainly
regional groups working autonomously
across the Middle East and North Africa
it's flourishing in week and failed
states such as Somalia and Nigeria it's
also believed to have a strong wing in
Yemen Yasin mashaba certainly al Qaeda
has left its mark on the political
discourse on a global scale in the past
10 years or so the question now is
though is al Qaeda perhaps even stronger
than it used to be before nine eleven
stronger is probably a problematic term
but more careful yes and the reason I'm
saying that is because one must not make
the mistake of looking at al Qaeda only
through the lens of somebody who lives
in the West if we ask the question are
they more capable today than they were
ten years ago to attack the West that
kill large numbers of people I'd say the
answer is no they are not but they are
very very careful in other regions and
particularly all across the Middle East
North and Africa and parts of
sub-saharan Africa even so this is where
we are seeing that al Qaeda is a real
threat to a whole lot of people capable
and able to kill thousands of them over
the next year's and that doesn't mean
that you have to be afraid of al Qaeda
when you live in Colorado in the United
States but if you live in any of those
countries in the Middle East or North on
Africa yes you should be afraid of al
Qaeda you in there there's there's a lot
of reasons why you should be afraid and
AB somali you're saying the argument is
being made that indeed al Qaeda is
perhaps even a bigger threat now than it
used to be even before 911 because the
movement has mutated if you will it has
spread from western Africa to South Asia
with numerous
affiliates something 41 affiliates 28 or
29 of them did not even exist before in
911 and is that also the understanding
in the Arabic world that al-qaeda today
in its current and present form the most
the more mutated and spread form is even
more dangerous the more followers
al-qaeda gets the more dangerous it gets
because the followers can potentially
turn into attackers into people who
would really take part in to the
violence and the problem is that
structural factors do help people and
like followers to slowly start stop and
take real the side of the al-qaeda
because they're poor because they are
ignorant because they don't have chances
in life for social mobility so you have
to consider that it's more than al-qaeda
and the ideology of al-qaeda it's also
the fact that there are people who are
desperately and frustrated they have
nothing in life to lose when they take
carry out violent attacks play which I
find interesting and important and that
is that up until the death of Osama bin
Laden al Qaeda was very careful not to
have its own brand mixed with that of
other organizations under Zawahri we are
seeing a move away from that al Qaeda is
mingling into regional and local affairs
across a lot of countries and is working
together cooperating with other local
organizations that have a similar
jihadist but regional focus and we have
not seen that before al Qaeda doesn't
care about the brand name as much
anymore as they used to but they're
still there they're mixing with these
people they're planning operations and
we've seen that in Mali for example
we're seeing in Nigeria we're seeing it
Somalia we're seeing it in the Sinai so
this is a very careful development and
and Ruby Dennison indeed al Qaeda has
become seems to have become less of an
organization about individuals if you
were but more than that of an idea al
Qaeda has become an idea if you will in
ideology and look at for instance the
Boston bombings what are you going to do
with
the you know lonesome sympathizers who
share the same ideology but are not
necessarily affiliated with al-qaeda
it's very hard to run in I think there
are different levels of cooperation
people say they're still exists in
al-qaeda central Zawahiri the Egyptian
who once was not al-qaeda but was always
radical against Anwar Sadat and others
okay then outside of that area where of
course people are on the run we presume
he's in northern Pakistan there are
formal connections al-qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula operates out of Yemen
has long associated itself with the
al-qaeda name is today considered a
threat because an idea that moves young
men with guns to occupy territories to
take towns to enforce their rule of law
a sharia extreme onto the population
that is something that is more of a
danger than just the idea and single
actors and that's where i agree with you
from a human rights perspective in the
wake of the Arab Spring that al-qaeda
has moved into places or Salafis serve
any kind of radical and and I think
oppressed people horribly that's it
that's a terrible thing we in America
used to say those horrible situations
could lead to an attack on the United
States today we tend to say that might
be localized and maybe we don't have to
worry keep him from getting too big let
them kill each other it's horribly
cynical but Americans have always had
their enemies fight against each other
the thing is the thing is what we're
seeing right now is that the pendulum is
swinging back I mean what is the idea
about al-qaeda the founding idea that
the principle on which al-qaeda is
founded is the idea that you should
attack those Western powers who support
what al-qaeda perceived as the local
dictators Mubarak and alike and the
likes of him now they are gone now most
of them are gone now and instead what we
have is a huge battlefield in Syria half
a battlefield in the Sinai
another big one in Libya so interests of
people are focusing now on their own
region they don't care so much about
attacking America right now there might
still be plenty of people trying to plot
something big against the US but this is
not the number one agenda of people who
identify themselves as al-qaeda fighters
their main focus at the moment is the
region but that may change again maybe
in ten years it's going to be looked at
looking different again so there's a
pendulum here that is swinging back al
Qaeda always calls it attacking the near
enemy and the far enemy at the same time
now each one of those ideas has
precedence at some point in time and
it's but you always have both ideas at
play but for now the shift of the focus
seems to have indeed change if you were
less away away from striking the US
homeland and more towards striking US
interests abroad such as Benghazi or or
even or even interests that they
perceive hostile and that are you know
Arab or Muslim targets and after some
Ali Hosseini if one were to ask what is
the goal of al-qaida at the end of the
day we just discussed where they are
striking and and whom they want to get
rid of but what is the overall goal here
some people are saying is it to spread
or asking it to spread Sharia worldwide
is it just to establish and install
Islamic governments in a certain region
you have the answer to that we have two
main targets first they're combating
Americanism like they are anti-american
and they believe that Americans sustain
authoritarian dictatorship in our
countries like in the Arab world in
muslim-dominated countries the other
thing that they have in mind I wouldn't
say Sharia application I would just say
they are standing for Islamic
governments because you can see that in
Egypt for example they were supporting
Mohamed Morsi the ousted president while
they did not apply the Muslim
Brotherhood did not apply Sharia in the
year he rule so you can see that it's
not eminently about the Sharia
application it's more or less supporting
Islamic Islamic guided
governments the longer term the targets
are the more theological they tend to
become so if you ask al Qaeda fighters
what is your aim in the end they will
always say the world domination of Islam
and one true Islamic caliphate all
across the globe and but that's the
long-term perspective if you ask for the
short-term goals it's very different
sometimes and or the medium-term goals
and it's interesting if you ask them
that and I tried to do that every time I
come across a sympathizer somebody who
identifies himself as such and because
if you look at those who are fighting in
Syria right now a lot of them are saying
well when we are done with our side we
are going into Israel so they're already
planning the next step it is not all
about Assad the foreign fighters from
all North Africa we're fighting with
al-qaeda in Syria against Bashar al
Assad forces right now in the end it's
not about Syria and if you talk about
mid term targets you know the same sort
of thing applies everybody can come up
with something that you know makes sense
in his own jihadist career so it's not
very easy to say those are the three
goals of al-qaeda well then let's talk
about the hierarchy here for a second
you've already mentioned that sour here
you obviously stands still stands at the
top at is there such a high ricky still
left in a world where you have so many
al-qaeda sympathizers and affiliates
worldwide no I would say that their
strength lies in not having a hierarchy
having lots of self coordinating cells
where even if you get rid of one then
the other can still act of course if
those self coordinating scale the cells
have difficulty using the internet or
getting money through banks then you can
week that we can them you can contain
them they all have an objective but
first having a Caliphate in their region
and then spreading the borders of that
Caliphate but we should not forget when
we're talking about al-qaeda in the
Middle East that a Caliphate of sorts
already exists and that is Iran or
Persia a theocracy at least one rod
academe is a head Ayatollah who says
what the new president Ronnie should do
or not do and this state is developing
also nuclear weapons or at least the
nuclear capability at the same time it
is supporting Bashar al-assad
in Syria through Iraq into Syria you
still have to jump over Iraq which is
also of course torn between al-qaeda
loyal Sunnis and Shia who were supported
by Iran but we see that al-qaeda in
Syria is fighting Persian supported
Syrian troops and Lebanese Hezbollah
Shia militia the same kind of Civil War
we saw in the streets of Baghdad in 2006
so this al Qaeda is also very much
involved in the war with the Shia and we
shouldn't forget that either indeed the
sunni-shia divide is in the focus is it
in the focus of al Qaeda as well look
the first time that al Qaeda really
started to attack Shia Muslims was in
Iraq under the leadership of a zerg owie
and it was his idea and why did he do
that because he wanted a civil war in
Iraq because that would create
conditions under which his own al-qaeda
network could flourish and his target
also was to attack Jordan and then you
know liberate Palestine so it wasn't
about Iraq in the first place and nobody
in Al Qaeda before that ever really
cared a whole lot about Shia Muslims so
and fighting Shiar is of course part of
the agenda but I don't say I wouldn't
say it's very high on the list and there
are the things that are more important
to them and is there a coordination
between the various affiliates thing not
now i will say two things about this
first of all of course there is some
sort of hierarchy in place I mean
everybody knows I'm another why he is
the Emir and you know if ever he has a
chance to talk to you then that's an
order and you have to follow it you
don't have much leeway in that regard
and and there are the four branches who
also have their own local Emir and it's
clear that he can order people around
and communications are a problem money
is a problem we know all that and I
agree with you on that point but there's
another point I want to make and the
sounds ironic but I'm convinced it is
true we know less about Al Qaeda central
today than we did 10 years ago the
reason for that is that so many of the
Qaeda's that we really knew have been
killed by drones and we don't know who
replaced
we have no idea so what I'm saying is if
you come across a terror expert who
tells you about the leadership of al
Qaeda central asking me if you can name
the five top guys and tell you about
each of them three sentences he won't be
able to this is the thing we our
visibility is very bad at the moment
this is why I'm very careful and try not
to over-interpret questions like
hierarchy command chains we don't know
enough about that so you know if I made
that raises another issue should the
United States be investing all of its
money into listening to communications
or should we be trying to get people on
the ground in northern Pakistan to get
into those kind of organizations with
what we call human intelligence and I
think they're Americans do tend to err
on the side of caution and if we could
listen to your cell phone we're not
going to send some guy in there or some
Pakistani secret police agent that works
with us it has blood on his hands so I
think that is a challenge to get inside
the network even if we do keep them on
the run and keep shooting things at them
well I'm not a policy maker but here you
know if you look at the history of
terror organizations and how they end
you usually find that the military is
not very helpful you usually find is a
mixture of intelligence and police work
that really gets the job done so i think
that's there's a lesson there perhaps as
for the drone strikes they are effective
in a way but if you shoot all the guys
you know and the you know and
organization is still there who are you
going to shoot next and the targets of
the drone strikes do depend on people on
the ground as well and there you have to
be careful because sometimes the
rivalries within the group and you'll
get one guy saying that's the al-qaeda
guy you shouldn't find out no it's just
my bad on colors and just very briefly
especially in Yemen local sentiment it's
the same in Pakistan by the way local
sentiment of local population against
drone strikes is very very important and
it did not help the US win hearts and
minds well we've given up on that I fear
Chris well it certainly did not help the
US win hearts and minds f to some other
Usain and you've alluded to that earlier
during this conversation that it pretty
much makes if you will the job of alki
recruiters rather rather easy to recruit
from constant pool of angry young men if
you will who are outraged about you know
drone attacks on the part of the u.s.
that perhaps might or might not kill
innocent people as well so would you say
that that is a real problem that there's
a constant pool if you will have an
angry young man that al Qaeda I can
constantly draw from as long as US drone
strikes will continue American
internationalism played a huge role in
cultivating the followers of al Qaeda on
the other hand the structure factors we
mentioned about being frustrated having
no chances in life and also the fact
that Islam had always been an integral
part of the societies where Al Qaeda has
its followers hits like main followers
so you have to think about the three
factors altogether America was doing a
very bad job when they were intervening
in the domestic politics of countries
muslim-dominated countries in favor of
dictatorships at the same time it was
also the fact that Islam is very
important in these countries as a
cultural ingredient the people are like
millions of citizens are frustrated they
don't have jobs and they don't have a
proper life standard so think about all
the three together and then you have an
answer for the follower profit profile
aeration Andrew Dennison the criticism
towards the United States is that during
this war on terror there has been way
too much emphasis on killing terrorists
and none on removing if you will the
incentive the grievances that make
people join terrorist organizations such
as al-qaeda in the first place would you
agree with that sentiment I think that
we have tried to democratize the Middle
East in order to drain the swamp so the
terrorists don't have grievances give
power to women education to children
freedom to business remove corruption
and it's been extremely difficult we
tried that in Iraq it really didn't work
didn't work in Afghanistan either in two
thousand seven forty percent of the
Americans said we need to focus on
internet
national affairs forty percent said we
need to focus on domestic affairs in
2013 eighty-three percent of the
Americans say focus on domestic affairs
and six percent say focus on foreign
affairs we don't want to mess with the
Mideast any more than we have to and in
that sense I think also Germany and
Europe much closer to that area have to
think about what the Middle East is
going to look like with a less engaged
United States but but let's look at the
role of the United States once more here
yah sandwich are much because obviously
and first and foremost the US was the
target of 911 and continues to be so and
and things like the drone strikes like
want animal like Abu Ghraib these are if
you will you know these are incidents
and phenomenons where the Arabic world
is outraged and even perhaps someone who
might not otherwise be inclined to be
radicalized might be drawn into that
sort of motion although I'm like I don't
know if I'm not sure how to put this
given that you have a global audience
but when the Abu Ghraib scandal broke of
course the Arab world was shocked but
then again they only you know would have
had to look into their own prisons to
see very much of the same thing so I'm
you know I'm not saying it's not right
to get angry over upgrade but is
definitely right and it was a terrible
terrible crime but the US holds itself
up to a higher standard exactly and and
of course you know there's a lot of
disappointment India's it's not I know a
lot of people who don't hate the United
States so much as they are disappointed
with them and and that can also be a
factor I guess it's like disappointed
love I mean I when I wrote my book I you
know I said a lot of a lot of people who
go to you know and buy a ticket to jihad
would probably also take a green card if
you offered it and their lives could
probably turn out very differently so so
I guess what we are really looking at is
we are looking at young people
especially young men who want to do
something meaningful and they will do
whatever is open to them and whatever
their environment tells them is the
right thing to do if their environment
was different if they had been exposed
to other ideas then there
would choose different paths it's not a
biological thing it's not an historical
a rule that people go way to jihad and
kill other people you know this can be
turned into positive energy as well and
I think when the revolution started in
Tunis in Egypt at the beginning of this
and we saw we had an idea of what this
positive energy could look like and a
lot of people who were on the streets in
Egypt you know at the same motivations
that some of the people who went to
fight some other players head so so I
think we need to create an environment
that makes positive views of the energy
that is there the energy I mean if ever
there was a time or a place to change
the future of the Middle East it would
be Egypt today 80 million people a
pillar with Western connections long
history with with a liberal open-minded
society at the same time at the edge
because of that frustration the
extremists it's a game but what can we
do two years it's money and I'll give
them time two years three years is
nothing and two years is Napoleon we are
trying what we are trying to do right
now is we are trying to life analyze the
French Revolution yeah but that took 200
years wouldn't really say that it was
quite a positive energy it was a
positive development in the sense that
Egyptians were capable of expressing
their views and standing for their
rights and freedoms and saying we want
Mubarak out but it was quite amazing how
once mubarak was ousted they just went
home so it was not really that you had
millions of people on the street for at
least 18 days and at the very end it was
just Mubarak was out they did not
realize the fact that it was more
structural and more profound than just
one person and that the corruption and
the this petition that Egypt suffered
from was more than just one person and
this is actually what they realized one
year later when they had the military
rule and then of course when they had
the Muslim Brotherhood president and
Parliament they even knew better about
their lessons being learned all the time
that's the good thing about it you know
when you look at how lost al-qaeda was
at the beginning of the Arab revolutions
that was also important to see that now
they have regained ground we all agree
on that but for those first two or three
months they didn't know what to say and
what to make of
that and the audion ish ative was some
other place and Ruby Dennison after
everything we further do you think it's
time to rethink the whole concept the
notion of the war on terror al-qaeda is
still here and is the us more safe you
could argue some would say US homeland
is more safe but at the end of the day
our US interests abroad almost safe do
you think it's time to reevaluate the
whole war on terror I think that you
have to reevaluate the war on terror
every day it is constantly rapidly
changing as the world awakens
politically from Tunisia to Yemen we've
seen what's happened it's been chaotic
it's a difficult time right now these
revolutions didn't turn out like East
Germany or the Czech Republic of course
West Germany paid a whole lot more money
into the East and it's willing to put
into into into that area but I think we
have to keep focused on human dignity
unlimited government and human rights
also on preventing big States from
consolidating power to develop nuclear
arsenals also a problem and so many
challenges but i don't think the Mideast
is going to go away so europeans and
americans need to stay engaged they need
to stay engaged yeah SEMA shabaash do we
have to live with al-qaeda a lot of
people are saying when is al-qaeda
defeated when is al-qaeda eliminated but
at the end of the day isn't it the fact
of matter of fact that we perhaps have
to learn to live with this phenomenon
called well I mean that the phenomenon
is going to collapse eventually but it's
going to collapse because the
environment changes in which it lives
not because of anything we do we can
help speed up the process but I think
what we are seeing right now is we are
doing one thing like drowning the hell
out of al-qaeda and we're seeing their
reimagined at the end so it's not really
sustainable the war on terror as it is
being led now even if it is much cleaner
than it used to be it is not entirely
sustainable nobody has found the recipe
or the silver bullet so this is going to
stay with us for a while the Middle East
needs to change and then I believe
organizations like Al Qaeda and the best
of circumstances may collapse overnight
but I'm not the one to predict
I just hope that AB somali you're saying
some would argue that al-qaeda has
already won they have already won
because there's a psychology of fear and
Western society as you see it every day
and you see it even through the closing
of the embassies of the US embassies in
North Africa and the Middle East would
you agree has al-qaeda one it had been
the case since September 11 because the
mobility of terrorist organizations and
the fact that there is a lack of
visibility to these organizations their
size the financing and everything always
constituted a threat and will always be
the case because we do not see them and
they move all the time this is not a
conventional war where two states go to
fight with armed troops it's totally
different and this is why I think the
threat is going to continue I think is
one I think and if they don't win they
lose their proclaimed objectives are to
take power of a state to take a
government and to run that government
and they have failed at that
consistently now it's true they have
taken advantage of civil wars but they
have not achieved our goal their goal
and I think we in the West do need to
put in perspective the the threats that
come from foreign terrorists they're
very limited you know people always
point out to me as an American that many
more Americans are killed by their own
guns than by any terrorist guns so we
need to continue to accept that it's
going to be around for a while but also
take it with a certain degree of
maturity maturities well we are trying
to but at the end of the day I'll SEMA
show us the same question goes out to
you has al-qaeda succeeded in its goals
no they have they haven't completed a
victory of anything but they are making
progress in ways that i found
disconcerting if you look into Syria
right now and you see I mean who is
feeding people in certain parts of our
leftover hums its al Qaeda they are
giving them bread and they're winning
supporters this way and that's bad I
don't like to see that and so that's
problematic to all that is indeed
problematic as it is the whole notion
and concept of al Qaeda still being
alive and I'm afraid to say perhaps even
well in light of the u.s. closings
of its consulates and embassies
worldwide I want to thank my guests for
their incredible insight into the
subject matter I want to thank you out
there for watching and tuning in and I'm
looking forward to seeing you again next
week for a new edition of quadriga